let's go
body cam images have taken us inside the
Covenant School as a horror unfolded now
there is audio of emergency 9-1-1 calls
that lay bare the fear panic and
confusion and staff and pupils hid from
a killer in the building
one was from an adult she says she was
hiding in an art room closet she hears
gunfire and tells children with her to
be quiet are you in a safe spot right
now
are you hearing shots now
no okay I thought we were in the
apartment closet okay
yes I hear another shot
hearing more shots okay okay upstairs by
the original hallway
you're upstairs by one hallway
in the art room art room yes please
hurry up you're coming they're coming we
just try okay try to stay quiet I don't
know what's going on there okay but um
another call is made by adults escaping
the school one provides a description of
the killer in camouflage I also was a
man holding an assault rifle shooting
through the door okay it was here he's
currently in the second grade hallway
second grade stairs okay
man why this camouflage the best gun in
a assault rifle camouflage on
Thursday saw a protest for stricter gun
control at the Tennessee State
Legislature emotions are raw here the
more they learn about the murder in
their midst the more it amplifies their
call for change
James Matthews Sky News Washington